all right who is ready
for another episode of mooco's corner
i mean y'all liked the first one i can
tell if it was just that you liked the
corner or you liked the lego or what but
i'm going to interpret it as you want
more of this so
we doing it hey everyone how's it going
my name is miyuko and welcome back to my
channel where we talk about
tech career and life so today i thought
it would be kind of cool to talk about
my career thus far by talking about
some of like the most pivotal moments
that got me to be
where i am today i mean i don't know
about you but i love thinking about like
okay how did i get here well that
happened because i met this person i met
that person because i met this person
and i met this person because i liked
this thing blah blah blah like
and so on and so forth i think it's fun
to kind of like chase down that rabbit
hole
and to really think about like what are
the really pivotal moments that have
really led me to where i am today
i mean i just think it's super cool to
like think about it just makes me think
how
random the universe is and just how a
lot of things happen because of a
million
random independent events of course
they're not always independent and
there is a lot of is it will or is it
fate
is like a kind of debate i guess that
could be mixed into here but
yeah today we're going to talk about my
life not technical stuff not software
engineering
stuff but career and life oriented i
know last time while i talked we built
some legos because it was about personal
projects if you missed it
check it out up here but today because
we're talking about the intricate web
of happenings around the world and in
everyone's individual lives that lead
to certain events i thought it would be
cool if we
did some crafting in the last like
couple of months ever since i probably
moved i've just been much more into
crafting
and it's just really satisfying to be
able to make something with your two
hands that
is just actually like physical and
tangible
so i thought we'd make like a super
duper simple macrame plant hanger
because i've been making a ton like i
used
most of this already and why not you
know you'll still get the content you'll
get a little bit of how-to entertainment
and if not just stay and subscribe for
my quirky personality
okay so this video is honestly probably
going to be pretty windy
and sort of all over the place i will
leave timestamps down below
to lead you to any sort of structure
of a video if you'd like to skip to any
parts and also before i start i just
wanted to acknowledge that
yes well a lot of these events have led
to really specific things happening
uh that's not the full story these are
not the only reasons why
i've had the career that i've had
there's gonna be a lot of like
behind the scenes things that i'm not
able to like put a figure on on how i
was able to
get to whatever step and i just wanted
to to acknowledge that like
idiosyncrasy make it like not feel like
a how-to
of like these are the steps that if you
follow exactly you'll have the same
results cause
you probably won't and that's just life
because everyone's different and walks
their own path
so it starts with tennis my parents
are both tennis players my mom played
high school tennis and then my dad
started playing tennis once we moved to
california
even before my parents generation my
grandfather
and my grandmother were out of tennis
players in their university
i really think that's where the story
starts as crazy as it is and as it might
sound
but it is kind of the the beginning to
my career actually
oh and by the way all the people that i
mentioned in this video were going to be
like nicknamed and named different
things to protect their privacy
and also because i haven't talked to
them in like a super long time and it'd
be awkward if all of a sudden i was like
yo
hey remember how you like changed my
life because my parents played tennis
i also played tennis uh i kind of think
that the whole tennis thing was
something that my dad really wanted to
do with me and my brother so
i played tennis in high school i joined
the junior varsity team
in high school and it was through tennis
that i met my friend
tom tom was like a year older than me
and he was also another asian kid at my
school
and we both played tennis and we ended
up just kind of having
the same circle of friends and it was
through my friend tom that i met my
friend
joe and i met him because tom invited
him to one of our many
like friend hangouts funny story i
actually like ended up dating him for a
little bit in high school
will i finish this within one video
honestly
probably not but i will make good
progress and
that's all that counts because you know
also like
the whole weaving of life and the
threads of life
are not complete ever so you know maybe
i'll leave this in an incomplete state
because that's just
what life is like so yeah because i
played tennis and i met my friend
tom i met my friend joe and then it was
through my friend joe
who i met my friend fred now fred went
to the same
high school as joe and he was japanese
i didn't really have very many japanese
friends growing up he was also a year
older than me so i was like
cool japanese friend and it also turns
out that where his family's from in
japan was pretty close to mine so we
shared the same dialect
and liked a lot of the same tv shows and
comedy so this was around like
junior and senior year of high school so
for those of you not in america this is
like the last two years of high school
before college
and fred was a year older than i was and
so he was in college and it turns out
that he went to ucsd
and in my senior year i had decided to
go to ucsd
and so it was nice that i was friends
with someone who was already there
and so when i got to ucsd i immediately
joined the japanese student association
which was a student organization that he
was a part of i was also just really
excited to hang out with like other
japanese people because i just like
never really had japanese friends to
begin with and kind of a parallel story
to this
while i was at ucsd i was living in the
dorms for my first year
and it just so happened that my
floormate will call him calvin
was the one that recommended that i try
computer science so yeah another like
if i hadn't lived in the dorms on that
floor
with my friend calvin they never have
found computer science
or maybe i would have who really knows
so yeah i was
starting computer science i was part of
this thing called japanese student
association
and through jsa i met my friend eduardo
eduardo was part of
jsa but he was also part of a
engineering student organization
so in my second year because of all the
stuff that i had heard from him about
how good it was to join new york i was
like
sure yeah i already know him i will
probably like everybody else so let's
join it
so that's how i joined this organization
it's actually called the
taw it's actually a fraternity yes i was
in a fraternity
in college but it was co-ed and i had a
lot of fun being in that student org
granted
everyone was an engineering student so
everyone was stressed
out all the time but it was nice that we
always had study buddies and someone
would always be in the labs to go
hang out with and study with also this
is turning out pretty good so far check
that out right
things are starting to leave together
things are starting to become
a thing i think at this point actually i
want to add a little
bead because you know what maybe it's
like a turning point in the story and
really
you are the writer of your own story and
journey so
because i'm the writer and storyteller
of
this beautiful macrame project i'm gonna
do it
you know that's what i feel like doing
and i'm gonna do it which is really
how many life decisions rituals
and things get made when you just say
you know what
just gonna do it because it feels right
and your gut is usually
not wrong there are times where you can
betray you and that sucks but
i found that listening to your gut
instinct has been
you know generally good so long as that
i it's actually
like an instinct that i want to trust
it's looking pretty good by the way if
you also want to learn how to make your
own macrame plant hanger or maybe you
want to learn how to cook
or you want to learn how to code
something or design
or draw or illustrate or really anything
at all then make sure to check out
today's sponsor
skillshare skillshare is an online
learning community for lifelong learners
creatives and curious people the classes
include a combination of video lessons
and class project and they all fit to
your schedule and skill level for less
than 10
a month with an annual subscription it's
curated specifically for learning so
there's no ads
and they're always launching new premium
classes i know that a lot of y'all are
like coding types but macrame is
actually very fun to make
so i really recommend the macrame plant
hanger diy class i'll link it in the
description box down below
but there's also so many other classes
to take from on skillshare
and for those of you who don't care to
make macrame but you want to learn some
really good technical skills then
there's a really popular class on
skillshare
called the javascript toolkit right
cleaner faster and better code
so the first 1000 people to use the link
in the description box down below we'll
get a free
trial of the skillshare premium
membership this is an awesome
opportunity to learn something new right
before the year ends and so make sure to
check it out
and thank you skillshare for sponsoring
okay so where was i
i had joined data tall i had met my
friend eduardo
so it was through the utah that i had
also met my friend
stephen stephen was two years older than
me he was also computer science
and so he gave me a lot of advice for
like how to move forward
in the industry and how to get a job it
just so happened that stephen had an
internship at intuit and he had a
returning offer
and so he was gonna go work there
full-time which was really cool because
when it came time for me to probably
look for an
internship in my junior year then i
called on him because he was already
working and had graduated at the time
and i was like yo
can you help me get a job into it and he
was like yeah i got you i'll give you a
referral which
is how i got my internship at intuit so
like
you'll notice so far that just like my
career until that point had really just
been a lot of like
bouncing around meeting lots of
different people and it just so happens
that a few
key people were really important for me
to have met
because it translated to them showing me
the way in opening the door
to opportunities that i had had which
i'm so grateful that i have met them
and that i became friends with them and
they helped me through all of this
which is kind of a big reason why i
wanted to make this youtube channel
because i wanted to hopefully
do a similar thing for you all i'm gonna
add some yarn
and make it a little bit fall rusticy
just try to make it
work here we go we can do this we can do
this we can do this
mango you can code you can make some diy
things too
okay i believe in you do i regret doing
this a little bit
yeah just like how at many times i
completely regretted
choosing computer science as my degree
when i was in college
but i just kept going with it because i
was like you know i'm more than halfway
done already
i've seen the worst of it i hadn't and
let's just see what happens if i keep
going and it might turn out to be
something really cold in the end which
it has sure that looks
decent it's a little bit imperfect but
you know what
everything in life is a little bit
imperfect and it's okay to live with
those imperfections sometimes because
that's what makes it feel
a little bit more human and makes you
feel like you are
alive that's the pattern that i'm gonna
go with for all of these i think
okay what was i talking about so yeah i
had gotten my internship at into it
successfully thanks to my friend stephen
and then so because i had an internship
at intuit
i then had a returning offer to intuit
for a full-time role
so yeah i worked it into it for a year
and a half in the middle of it after a
year i knew that i wanted to move up to
the bay area
so i did through an internal transfer
into it which wasn't so hard because i
was part of a rotational program anyways
and so that's how i made it all the way
up to silicon valley
to the bay area but what i didn't know
at the time is that i would be at that
job for six months because i didn't
really particularly enjoy it
and then i would move on to my next role
and that as
a lot of you know is patreon and patreon
like i wish i could say there was like
this like oh my goodness
there's this person that introduced me
to patreon blah blah blah blah blah like
there isn't like
another part of my story is angel list
i was like just on my laptop one day
perusing all the different job listings
and just kind of being like what
else is out there for a young ios dev
like me and then i had found the patreon
listing at the very top of the list and
i feel like it struck me with lightning
where i was just like
i gotta do this job and a lot of things
have built up to that obviously
like another part of the story which
i'll get into in a bit is how i started
youtube and what are all the things that
happened there
but i think why i started youtube and
why i started working at patreon share a
very similar
storyline in that i just watched a lot
of youtube
in high school and college and i just
was a youtube theme
and while i was in college i
specifically knew that
creators like keem grannis and destin
from smarter every day and many other
creators i had looked up to
were using patreon so it was a familiar
name to me and
because i wanted to work on something
that i was you know passionate about
that i'd be really excited by
i decided to apply there and
interestingly actually
i didn't hear back from patreon for like
an entire two months
and so between the time that i applied
to when i got a response back
i had actually interviewed with several
other companies i had gotten offers from
them
and i had signed one already but i still
was like i just want to see if patreon
will
take me basically i don't know if i'll
i'm even qualified for the job
i just want to see if this is this could
be a thing so i emailed patreon i was
like yo
i applied to your thing a couple months
ago like i have offer
already i just want to like see if you'd
still be down
to see if this whole thing could work
and luckily one of the recruiters
reached out to me thank goodness
uh we did the whole interview and i had
to make a really tough decision
of reneging reneging reneging free
this word i had to go back on the
offer that i had accepted because in my
heart i knew that
what i really wanted to do was work at
patreon so yeah then i worked at patreon
uh i worked there for two and a half
years as many of you know
and then while i was a patreon i think
it was like
after a year of working there i went to
vidcon
and a lot of y'all know this part of the
story because i've shared it a lot but
vidcon was like where it all started for
me in terms of youtube
because i had gone originally to gain
empathy
for creators but then when i left i just
had all this insight about basically how
to be a creator
and also patreon was how i met jarvis
and
we basically were just like dude let's
just build youtube channels together
and so we started building our channels
around the same time and that was
it was a really fun fun time and i think
jarvis is also a really important part
of this journey because
he just helped me through a lot of stuff
we were figuring it out together and
it was fun i just remember the first day
that he got his camera because we were
like oh my gosh are we actually doing
this like you're actually gonna like
have the full set up and like make
videos and now look at us like we're
both
doing it so yeah put a pin on the whole
youtube journey for a little bit yeah i
worked a patreon for two and a half
years
um had a super fun time working there
but there was a point where i was like
i gotta go like this is this is the end
of the road for me and so it was around
that time that i was
starting to think about leaving that i
just so happened to get an email in my
inbox
that was an invitation for an event at
netflix and that invitation came from
let's call her jocelyn who would later
on
become my manager at netflix her and
other managers were hosting this
women in ui engineering event at netflix
hq and i was like sure i know that
netflix events are really good because i
had gone to a couple at that point
and so i went and that's where i met
jocelyn and
i remember when i met her because i was
just like i'm not really
you know seriously thinking about
leaving just yet
but just in case i do think of doing
that like are you hiring and she was
like
yes we are we had already made contact
she knew who i was i know who she was
and
it was just a matter of being like yeah
i'd like to do the interview
and passing along my resume and a cover
letter and stuff and luckily
they liked me i did well in the
interview and so i got that job
and so while i was there i definitely
thought a lot about like what do i want
to do next i actually had conversations
with jocelyn about this
and so eventually i realized that i want
to
not work in tech for a little bit and
take a break and so that's what i did as
you all know
i didn't really know that i was gonna
become a full-time content creator
just yet but i did know that i didn't
wanna work as a software engineer
okay we're gonna embark upon this
journey again
in which mooco tries to be crafty thread
number two
done so yeah that's kind of the story of
my career which can be told through
its pivotal moments which leads all the
way back to
my parents playing tennis which is like
history is weird
and it's so fascinating at the same time
now i'm doing full-time content creation
and i don't know that there's any one
point in which i was like
this is what i meant to do if anything
it's been a very slow like
i don't know if i want to do this
because it's super scary and i don't
know what i'm doing whatsoever but
it is something that i want so i'm going
to try and make slow and steady progress
towards it
but i will say that a day in the life of
a software engineer my very
very first video did kind of make a big
difference i think
and i know a lot of y'all watching that
video like that was like the first video
of mine that you watched because the
algorithm recommended it and the fact
that it has millions of views
is still absolutely mind-boggling oh and
then i guess a note on that video
i decided to make that video both
because of right after i had been to
vidcon and i was like i want to make a
video
but i also attribute that to like the
hours and hours of ghibli movies that i
grew up with like i just really like
slice of life content and i remember
that when i was making that video that's
exactly the kind of thing
that i wanted to make which is why i
don't talk in that video which is why
there's little word bubbles and stuff
it's very chill relaxing easy music
which
the music has stuck around because i
love
lo-fi and jill hop stuff it's kind of
crazy that life turns out that way
i mean i think really the moral of the
story here is that you never know what's
gonna happen
people that you meet the jobs that you
get
the opportunities that show up the
opportunities that you accept that you
reject
all of these things amount to hopefully
a beautiful and glorious and full and
rich life and if not it's working
towards one and so in the context of
like
career software engineering anything at
all
if there is an opportunity to try
something and you are at least a little
bit interested
then go for it because you never ever
know what's gonna happen
it might you know two or three steps
ahead of that help you meet
the love of your life or maybe it'll
help you achieve a goal of yours that
you've had for your entire life
you never know and i think that's the
kind of like optimism and hope that
i try to have especially this year
because it's really
hard to you never know what the future
is going to hold
i think if we look at past history a lot
of bad
has happened but also a lot of good
things have happened too
as a result of many tiny individual
accidents really and of course in
between all of the events
is a lot of hard work crying figuring
out
what your life is supposed to mean and
not knowing what the heck you're
supposed to do
even in the face of something super
terrible everything will be
okay and life is never complete you're
never gonna get that like
i'm done i've achieved everything in
life because there's always more
i think that's kind of the beauty of
life really because as you leave
each strand into your life and it just
piles up to become
something super beautiful and nice
it'll create a really nice end product
am i trying too hard for analogy because
i'm trying pretty hard right now
i'm not done with this at all because
this takes like hours to make but i did
make some pretty good
progress but i will show you the done
state right here
see it's so pretty i finished it after i
filmed the video and now it's beautiful
probably hanging with the plant living
its best life so yeah thank you all for
being here and coming to
another edition of mooco's corner if you
have any other topics you'd like for me
to cover
then leave them in the comments down
below preferably with an activity i can
do that
with because i like adding like an
element of diy or making something here
while i talk to you all make sure to hit
that subscribe button and i will see you
next time
bye